hey there I'm Zachary Quinto and I am
gonna explain everything you need to
know about having electronic voting
machines as we approach election day how
vulnerable are we really what are the
problems most of these machines are
running Windows XP for which Microsoft
has not released a security patch since
April of 2014
most of these were installed after the
bush-gore recount debacle though there's
no evidence of direct voting machine
interference so far researchers have
determined that these machines are
susceptible to malware or equally if not
more alarming a well-timed
denial of service attacks so if you have
machines that aren't working that could
create problems that prevent people from
voting at all the extent of ulnar
ability is not just hypothetical late
last summer Virginia decertified
thousands of insecure wind' vote
machines as one security researcher put
at anyone within half a mile could have
modified every single vote undetected
with no expertise the wind vote scenario
is an extreme case but not an isolated
one what's the good news first it's
important to realize that electronic
voting machines aren't as commonplace as
one might assume three-quarters of the
country will vote on paper ballots this
fall only five states Delaware Georgia
Louisiana South Carolina and New Jersey
used direct record electronic or d-r-e
machines exclusively but plenty of other
states use electronic voting in some
capacity verified voting org has a handy
map of who votes using what equipment
for what it's worth electronic voting
machines have been this hackable in
previous elections and there's no
indication that there's ever been and
interference the even better news is the
three states that may decide the
election Florida Ohio and Pennsylvania
all have voting machines that are in
relatively good shape suspicions that
the results could be rigged however may
be the real danger of electronic voting
systems if you can't guarantee that
there was no tampering and not every
state can it might not matter if any
actually took place